how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course everything relating
to the MCU now there hasn't been a ton
of new information going around about
Marvel Studios as upcoming projects
movies and TV shows because everything
is shut down currently due to this
pandemic however we are still getting
some news that is leaking out as the
people over at marvel studios are still
having their meetings they're just doing
them over zoom meeting so things are
still moving over at Marvel Studios the
plans for the future are still going
forward they just can't really do much
as far as production wise right now and
apparently the people over at Marvel
Studios are cooking up something really
really big right now a project that
would involve the Fantastic Four Doctor
Doom the x-men The Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver
and Magneto now we all knew that the
x-men and the Fantastic Four were going
to be coming into the MCU pretty soon
Kevin Feige announced the x-men and the
Fantastic Four and Doctor Doom is said
to be one of the next big bats but one
thing that we didn't know is that
they're going to come in in a very
connected way one big storyline that's
going to tie them all together in that
storyline according to today's report is
the ultimatum a storyline and there are
five major takeaways that you need to
know about what the storyline means for
the future of the MCU so we'll break it
all down but if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU today's
report comes from MCU cosmic and
according to the site Marvel Studios has
begun development on ultimatum and
ultimatum will apparently be the next
big storyline in the MCU so for those of
you who are not familiar with the
ultimatum storyline it is a pretty
brutal storyline the story is about
magneto trying to destroy the world and
in the process he kills millions the
ultimatum storyline with magneto trying
to destroy the world starts off with
ultron shooting and killing the Scarlet
Witch hawkeye tries to kill magneto by
shooting an arrow at him but Quicksilver
takes the arrow and he dies as well now
in this ultimatum universe Quicksilver
and the Scarlet Witch are the children
of magneto now in this universe the
heroes all grouped together are called
The Ultimates and Magneto manages
to escape from The Ultimates but he also
manages to steal Thor's hammer first he
swears vengeance on the ultimate sand
using Thor's hammer and his magnetic
abilities he reverses Earth's polarity
this causes major lightning storms and a
tsunami to hit New York as well as
causing many other natural disasters
across the earth professor X using his
telepathic abilities discovers that
millions have died and he warns the
other heroes that magneto is the one to
blame they find that magneto is in a
floating Citadel and many of the heroes
including Professor X go after him to
stop him unfortunately this doesn't end
too well for many of the heroes that go
after magneto and many of them die
including the wasp angel dr. strange
Thor and Magneto himself even kills
Professor X and Wolverine ripping the
adamantium from his body and harming his
body in a way that his cells can't
regenerate so we really do see magneto
in the storyline had one of his most
powerful forms however it does go on to
reveal that dr. doom is actually the one
responsible for the scarlet witch's
death eventually magneto comes down from
his dissolution and he orders Cyclops to
blast his head off and which Cyclops
does it is then later revealed that
Quicksilver is actually alive and he
takes his father's helmet and he swears
vengeance on everyone so as you can see
it's a pretty brutal storyline that
involves many different heroes ranging
from the x-men to the Fantastic Four to
some of the Avengers as well and as I
mentioned there are five very important
things to take away from this in regards
to the future of the MCU the first thing
to take away is that we may have an
Avengers type of film without the actual
Avengers based off of reports in the
past it does look like Marvel Studios
plans on introducing the x-men one at a
time or two at a time and not
introducing them in one big x-men film
so we'll have solo movies and they'll
also be introduced in other movies like
Captain Marvel 2 but then all of the
x-men will come together for x-men film
this will be like the Avengers coming
together for the Avengers film just like
we were introduced to the heroes
individually Ironman Thor and Captain
America it looks like the same will
happen for the x-men before they come
together and then we have the Fantastic
Four who are going to be introduced in
one movie because they are a group with
the x-men comes magneto and with the
Fantastic Four comes Doctor Doom so
there will be a story revolving our
around all of these characters until
they eventually come together to team up
against Magneto ending dr. doom so since
this is going to be an Avengers type of
movie the actual Avengers probably
aren't going to be that involved it's
more going to be about the new
properties in the MCU the x-men and the
Fantastic Four
so the MCU can start to have major
movies involving major characters that
aren't necessarily The Avengers
the second thing that you need to know
about the store line is that it sets up
an Avengers infinity war and end game
type of film as well yes there will be
movies for the Fantastic Four in the
x-men when they come together but
eventually there will be a film where
the Avengers the x-men and the Fantastic
Four all get together to fight multiple
different villains this will set the
stage for our next Avengers in-game
level type of event in the next 10 years
or so and this will be when we finally
see all of these new characters all the
properties that are coming over from Fox
team up together the x-men the Fantastic
Four and our beloved Avengers will all
be finally in one movie teaming up the
third thing is that we're going to see
Magneto be introduced in a film in a way
that we have never seen him before in
this storyline the reason that he
decides to destroy the earth is because
of the death of his children The Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver as I mentioned in
the ultimatum storyline magneto shifts
Earth's polarity and this is a worldwide
catastrophic event much like half of the
people from Earth were wiped away with
vanos a snap it seems like a lot of
people are going to die at the hands of
magneto and it's all going to be fueled
by his rage if Marvel decides to stick
true to the storyline and if that's true
that means that Quicksilver could be
returning there have been many reports
and there has actually been some scripts
leaks that say Quicksilver is returning
after all Aaron taylor-johnson the actor
who played Quicksilver in Avengers age
of Ultron does have more projects left
on his contract with Marvel Studios so
he could come back and the Wanda vision
show that's coming to Disney Plus but if
he does it looks like him and his sister
The Scarlet Witch may meet their fate
now it doesn't seem very likely that
Marvel Studios would kill off the
Scarlet Witch however that doesn't mean
that some catastrophic event couldn't
happen in the MCU to set magneto off but
whatever the reason it seems pretty
clear that the x-men's first true enemy
is going to be magneto the fourth major
thing that this could possibly reveal
if Marvel Studios decides to stick true
to the ultimate storyline is how the
x-men are going to come into the MCU at
the end of the ultimate story line
before magneto dies Nick Fury using the
telepathy powers of Jean Grey transmits
memories into Magneto's mind these
memories show him that the existence of
mutants was in fact the result of a
misguided genetic super-soldier
experiment an experiment that happened
decades ago of merging Nick Fury super
soldier blood and the DNA of Wolverine
and this could actually be the way that
Marvel Studios does decide to introduce
mutants into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now it's widely speculated that
Black Widow could introduce Ursa Major
who is a mutant the actor the Dutch
giant is confirmed to be playing a role
in the Black Widow film and he hinted at
himself plain Ursa Major Black Widow is
also going to heavily deal with the
Super Soldier Serum and we even see
vials of this in the trailer for Black
Widow we know that all of the black
widows that are in the Red Room training
have been given the Super Soldier Serum
to enhance their abilities but we also
know that the serum is how they're being
controlled as well we also know that
Thunderbolt Ross is going to be
searching for the serum as well and it
is interesting that they would bring
back Super Soldier Serum in the
beginning of phase 4
however Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige has said that the Black Widow film
is going to have a major impact on the
future of the MCU and it could be that
experiments done with the Super Soldier
Serum and humans could create mutants
and perhaps Ursa Major could be the
first mutant that we actually see in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the fifth and
final thing that you need to know about
the ultimatum storyline is that it will
most likely lead up to Avengers secret
Wars battle world the event where the
Avengers the x-men the Fantastic Four as
well as many different villains
including Galactus and Doctor Doom all
come together in one huge movie just
like infinity war and endgame over the
next ten years or so Marvel is going to
continue to build up the new Marvel
Cinematic Universe with all of its new
characters and former characters as well
and it all has to lead up to something
there has to be some big finale
just like Avengers in game and the
events of this ultimatum stone
we'll set up god-emperor doom and in the
avengers secret wars battle world
storyline God Emperor Doom is God he
manages to steal the powers from the
Beyonder and he creates the battle world
god emperor doom combined with Galactus
are going to be the two next big bad
villains of the MCU which the Avengers
the Fantastic Four and the x-men will
most likely have to go against in
Avengers battle world so there's
actually a lot about the future of the
MCU that this ultimatum storyline
reveals but with the x-men and the
Fantastic Four head into the MCU very
soon now this is what we have to look
forward to and again it could reveal a
very good way that the mutants could be
introduced into the MCU but let me know
what you think about this how excited
are you for the x-men and the Fantastic
Four to finally enter the MCU and is
this a storyline that you can get
excited about be sure to drop your
comments and thoughts in the comments
down below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe with notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we're also going to
be starting weekly giveaways next week
and for live updates you can follow me
on Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof